world war iii is racing civil war
because while we're hearing about
stories in like west virginia about
bombs we have this one a murder in
russia
i'm sure many of you have already heard
i believe it was saturday saturday
evening alexander dugan's daughter was
assassinated
in a car bombing
now initially they said it was meant for
him for those that aren't familiar with
dugan he is a highly influential
philosopher
nationalist in russia
he's been referred to as putin's brain
or his spirit guide or the spirit guide
of ukrainian invasion all of those
things while simultaneously some have
also downplayed his influence in the
russian government he's not explicitly a
member of putin's inner circle or
anything like that the atlantic writes
about it why an assassination in moscow
matters to ukraine and the west by tom
nichols oh we love this guy huh
he calls him a russian fascist
the daughter of a prominent russian
fascist was killed in a car bombing in
moscow most americans have no idea who
the dugan family is but this event could
have serious repercussions in russia and
ukraine
so
i don't want to jump the gun and say
that um
this is world war three's france
ferdinand moment
france ferdinand was a was a he was like
a royal royal family guy right the
archduke yeah and so when they killed
him like you've pissed off someone's
family member and then they all go to
war with each other this is like an
influential guy in russia's daughter
but then i want to point out too the
counterpoint there is while it well for
those reasons it may not be the catalyst
for an escalation
we're also in the influence era we're in
the you know the influence economy
so it is not necessarily politicians or
royal family that have the most
influence kim kardashian has more
influence than
every single politician and so something
someone who's that influential in in
social has more social credit than a
politician something affecting them will
matter more so so the way i described it
earlier today
if they had killed dugan i think the
impact would have been substantially
less
people in the russian government would
be like this is this is horrifying i
can't believe they did this
instead they killed dugan's daughter
whoever did it they uh it was reported
to by russian authorities cnn repeated
the reporting
that they were observing the vehicle and
remotely detonated they chose to
detonate it it wasn't like she turned
the car and it went off someone pressed
a button
so presumably they knew it was her
this is substantially worse
because dugan is the man of influence
and now
all of that pain that he has will be
channeled into the influence he uses and
it will be heard over and over and over
again by all of his followers and his
followers that are in the government
so this has now given him given him a
reason to call for more war more
retribution more anger and he will drive
that you know to his followers
honestly i don't know on his f on its
face it looks like ukrainians
killed dugan's daughter as retaliation
for the war in ukraine but i was reading
an article and they're like ah false
this is a this is a textbook russian
false flag could be a textbook russian
false flag operation and then i started
picturing like a conversation between
dugan and putin and dugan's like i would
give everything for this country
vladimir everything and vladimir's like
you would give everything and he's like
yeah i would and then putin's like all
right well then i'll kill his daughter
because he just he and i don't even feel
guilty about it because he already said
he'd sacrifice everything for it so
there reportedly he has said things
about sacrificing everything for the
cause and things like that but
to this extent i would just say
it is the simple solution that they blew
up his car and it was the wrong person
it's the simple solution that this guy
is a nationalist powerful influencer and
they wanted him gone i mean he's he's an
influential guy i mean people in the
west have interviewed him they his ideas
have spread all across europe not saying
they're completely completely dominant
across europe but a lot of people have
listened to this guy and if you take a
look at the right wing the expansion of
right-wing nationalism across europe
well there are certainly many people who
don't like nationalism or the right
who would look at him as one of the key
components of pushing those ideas
so occam's razor occam's razor would
suggest in the absence of evidence the
solution that makes the least amount of
assumptions that's it
anti uh you know um internationalist
forces
probably ukrainian
targeted him in moscow
killed his daughter
i'll put it this way too the reason it's
simple solution that's ukraine i'm not
trying to blame them to call them any
names or anything but to point out it's
probably them
when you are the weaker fighting force
typically you see these groups engage in
more terroristic activities and targeted
assassinations and things like things
like this because it's the best they
could do in the conflict for russia
they're looking at a conventional war
you go in send in the tanks send to the
troops drop the bombs
for ukraine which is i think like the
poorest country in europe and it's like
the only country to get poorer after the
fall of soviet union they're they're
they're thinking we have to do whatever
it takes and we don't have much
capabilities guerrilla warfare it is him
in moscow that seems to make more sense
it's the simplest solution for sure but
in war propaganda they will use the
simplest solution against you to make
you think that that's what it is i think
if they had assassinated dugan outright
they would have risked a more serious
retribution from
putin i disagree well my thought in here
is that his daughter dugan's daughter
was involved in his influence and she
she was also seen like not on the
international level that she was but
within the country she is an advocate
for his policies and beliefs so in some
way
she they are uh maybe
effectively hurting the morale of the
russian people by targeting by choosing
to
detonate the car when she was in it as
opposed to him
while still being able to like say it
wasn't quite as aggressive as outright
right detonating you know this person
who has tremendous influence in a
relationship with the nation's president
the the one thing that i would say that
is a counterpoint that suggests it may
actually be a false flag or you know
russians doing this because we actually
have a story here let me pull this up
from daily mail car bomb attack on
putin's rasputin who vladimir deemed
uncontrollable has all the hallmarks of
a russian gru execution because military
spy group often include a target's
family i don't see why they would go
after dugan they're saying because the
kremlin deemed him unruly
the one thing i would say that makes me
think it could be a false flag although
i don't think it is
getting his daughter
was the worst possible thing you can do
in terms of escalation
so to to disagree with you a bit
dugan's voice would be lost if he died
if your goal was to amplify his message
of nationalism
and get a martyr
you'd go after his daughter
because now you've got a martyr someone
who holds the same ideas as him who who
speaks the same ideas who is considered
by the west a propagandist who is
considered by you know russia as a
journalist
you get your martyr
you keep dugan's voice you amplify
dugan's voice with a major story about
how he's now a victim targeted by the
the the the um excesses of the west
now you've exemplified his message
amplified his message and created a
martyr all at the same time it's the
worst possible thing for escalation well
unless you're putin and you want to get
the russian people excited about
attacking ukraine because that's exactly
what i'm saying
i don't think it's true look i'm seeing
a lot of these democrats they're like he
killed his own daughter and i'm like
that's nuts that's crisis actor level
conspiracy nonsense sorry dude unless
you can come out and show me a video of
him
planting the bomb or whatever i'm not
going to believe he killed his own dog
i'm picturing putin going to uh
alexander and being like i'm so sorry
about your daughter and then making full
eye contact and alexander knowing that
putin killed her and just looking at him
like thank you sir like and they both
know it's just
dirty hollywood
exactly i don't think that that's
realistic i think in some ways we
believe that vladimir put putin and for
good reason is like uh an intense leader
who has committed crimes that like the
west finds horrifying
but i don't think that
there would be any benefit especially if
we already think this guy is unruly then
like being like and then i killed your
daughter like they could deemed him
unruly how do we know he's not going to
flip and be like i hate putin now you
know what i mean like it it doesn't do
anything for putin to try and antagonize
or play with a variable that isn't
dependable if they really do believe
he's unruly i think that i mean the most
to me the most straightforward answer is
like this was an attempted assassination
like i haven't read enough to know where
dugan was in relation to the car was
even there like
to me it makes more sense that they are
trying to
both be aggressive and also
passive-aggressive at the same time and
they see as taking out his daughter as
uh an aggressive move without
while still being able to say well we're
not the aggressors in this war so so to
your point ian you're saying you know
it's like you're imagining putin looking
in the eyes and it's very
hollywood-esque my counterpoint to that
would be
the reality is likely some fat
middle-aged ukrainian dude with a couple
bombs like waddling over the car and
then like slapping it with duct tape and
then walking away and then waiting for
it again and then pressing a button and
going oh and like running away like
scraggly dudes no like i'm not imagining
you know spetsnaz like commandos like
going in and like the earpieces and
they're like do it and then
it's probably it's probably it's rogish
it's guerrilla stuff it's probably like
hobo looking dudes you know who are
angry who are zealous and probably
ukrainian and there are a fair number of
ukrainians who have gone to russia since
the start of the war um so there is a
ukrainian population within the country
i mean i assume some are there because
they want to be and some are there maybe
because they had to go uh but it it
russia is not insulated from having uh
ukrainian actors be within its
boundaries i i don't i will not decide i
don't even like the word probable now
because war fog is so
the it's ripe for
for disillusionment and you want to
trick people and you want to create that
so
the most obvious answer a lot of times
when war is not the right answer the
open field that looks like the best path
is probably the kill zone so you don't
want to go through it kind of thing and
i'm going to wait and see if they use
this as is just as a reason to go harder
in ukraine than that's like russia is
saying ukraine did it of course someone
just super chatted in the pale moonlight
tim you guys know what that's a
reference to
no no star trek fans for shame uh deep
space nine um in the pale moonlight
brilliant television spoiler alert
spoiler alert it's like a 30 year old
show but i'm going to spoil it for you
uh benjamin cisco is the is the
commander of an outpost for the
federation the star trek
a war breaks out
the the federation which is the main
characters
are being defeated by they're slowly
being pushed back and they're losing the
war to the dominion
there's another race called the uh
romulans and they're typically there's
an armistice between the federation and
the romulans they hate each other
they they go to them and say you have to
join the war on our side otherwise after
we are defeated the dominion will come
and crush you and they're like
no they won't and we don't care we can
handle ourselves so the commander stages
a false flag where he blows up a senator
in a spaceship and plants evidence to
make it seem i could be getting this
wrong but something like this makes it
seem like the dominion did it forcing
the romulans to join the war on the side
of the federation
now that we've gotten the fictional fund
writing out of the way
there's a very possibility that the goal
here was a false flag and it was to
rally the the russian people saying look
they killed this young woman she was 29
years old they're targeting our children
this is horrible we need your support in
this war
and depending on what you read
western propaganda says
ukraine's winning
eastern propaganda says ukraine's losing
who knows man
of war it's an emotional assassination
that was not a tactical assassination
that didn't take out a leader or
military command or anything and car
bombs are crude
yeah super super crude and a lot of
collateral damage it was not a surgical
maneuver
well i'm i'm shocked that they would
claim that anyone has done it that they
would deign to act like they know who
did it and if they do know who did it
how do they know who did it
i want to know it doesn't matter and
that's ultimately what it comes down to
it doesn't matter who did you know why
because in the east they're going to say
in russia and in china they're going to
say it was
the uh ukrainians it was nato in the
west they're posting all over twitter
that it was a false flag that dugan
killed his own daughter because they
have to because both sides have to
there's a narrative they have to keep up
yep
and in the end we'll just be left
wondering what actually happened the
good news is whoever wins will tell us
for sure honestly well yeah they'll give
us the whole story like the history for
us the history books and then they'll
let us read them with all the details
don't even worry about it do you think
that the russians are going to just end
up taking the eastern part of ukraine
get access to the red sea and then it'll
be over
i don't know
as the surgeon general of florida all
right tell me about your opinions on
russia
i mean i think i agree that the part
that is interesting wouldn't it be nice
to actually know
what happened yes
and not of course it doesn't even end
with this right there's so many examples
in history where it's still unclear what
exactly happened
um who gained who lost who was behind
sort of who was
who was um
who was pulling the strings to to to you
know create a series of events it
certainly it does have the feel of that
that um you know not an accident i mean
it could have been and i agree that
that's sort of the simplest
answer you know occam's razor
but um boy it seems awfully dastardly to
to just have a simple explanation thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you